free trade between the EU and the US but
at what price t tip the transatlantic
trade and investment partnership has
raised concerns over issues such as
social and environmental dumping data
protection and private arbitration
courts isds in particular on Wednesday
Cecilia Malstrom explained to mep s why
the Commission wants to include is dsnt
tip no US law prohibits discrimination
against foreign investors putting
investment in the deal would close that
gap but only if the commitments are
enforceable and I SDS it's the only way
to enforce them because international
law cannot be invoked in US courts but
for many MEP is investment disputes
should not be solved by private
arbitration courts vermin gear invested
eightish chitin niche dean at tsunami
reached by chitin Lewis and kundan can
assign us one on internet snow and
sheets drifts off after night at MIT
Winnipeg English turn on drift on I mean
this Tigers enjoyed it as Parliament on
two chicken tikka masala and fear and
anger elope in Parliament built sublime
the midst in East we by actor Anil
ography and upcoming lived the next step
for the Parliament is to vote on a
common position on t tip in May